Russ is with us in Dayton Ohio hi Russ
how are you hey how are you better than
I deserve what's up so I'm an avid
Insight XM channel listener and they've
kind of reformatted and redid the
schedule I've been listening to you for
about maybe four or five days now huh
welcome and I'm I'm entry Joey welcome
good to have you thanks my basic
question is I'm gonna give you where I'm
at right now the next question is if you
were me what do I do
okay how old are you I'm 41 my wife is
36 - what do you do for a living I'm a
college professor awesome what's your
household income together 140 yes and we
put all at G maxes out or 401 K and I
have the you know State Teachers
Retirement cool good for you okay you
have any debt other than your home you
know I've got about 20 ish somewhere
around there in school loans that I'm I
am on year five of ten you know when I
reach ten years of teaching then I will
have them forgiven you know whatever's
the remaining balance we've got a seven
to eight thousand dollars on a car and
then our mortgage we're down to about 70
grand good for you are you doing really
well so what happened was about 30 years
ago I went completely broke I start
buying and selling real estate in my 20s
when I first got married and I got
deeply into debt and I had a great net
worth and a great income but a lot of
debt bank got sold to another bank
called our notes we spent the next two
and a half years of our life losing
everything we owned so by the time I was
28 I had been a millionaire and I was
bankrupt and I'm 58 now by the way okay
and so that that's kind of the
backstory on this of how we got at this
stuff because I have a finance degree
and all these other letters and licenses
after my name but our advice is not the
standard fare advice and part of it
comes from our story that's why I bring
that up because I don't ever want to go
back there again you understand that I'm
sure absolutely I I spent I have an
engineering degree and I went back for
my masters I spent a good 12 years
between 21 and whatever that you know at
12 years of that being a complete
screw-up okay well we're brothers in
okay so anyway we started coaching
people on the best way to build wealth
and we developed that over the years
into in great detail and with great
history and data large numbers of data
okay so it's not it's not a theory it's
and this is not textbook this is like
five million people have been through
our financial piece classes as an
example okay and you know I've been
doing this show almost thirty years now
I've been doing it 27 years so long time
before we got to XM right but anyway all
of that to say that this is a proven
system and we teach a thing called the
baby steps and it's the order in which
to attack your finances and it gives me
the basis to answer your question the
baby steps is the first baby step is
before you do anything save a thousand
dollars as a beginner starter emergency
fund now you probably have a savings
account in what you've described here
how much is in your savings account not
retirement 60 grand
okay so you've got a good emergency fund
okay your thousand dollars baby stand
during the first three baby steps we
temporarily stopped all investing until
we accomplished these foundational steps
in which upon which we're going to build
the rest of the house okay baby step two
is to become debt free everything but
the house the reason to do that is that
when you have no payments it's very it's
much easier to build wealth and increase
your generosity and those are you know
let me let me just saw a short suck
circuit let me let me go let me go fine
baby step three is once you're out of
debt everything but your home we would
have you build then upon your emergency
fund with $1,000 up to three to six
months of expenses those you do
specifically in order then baby steps
four five and six we do simultaneously
four is fifteen percent of your income
into retirement while we start saving
for college for kids that's five and
then any other money we can squeeze out
we throw at the house and pay off the
house early baby step six with your
income you're gonna be the baby step
seven which is a hundred percent
debt-free and maxing out all retirement
very quickly in your situation
so having applying that to your numbers
very quickly what I would do is just pay
off your car and your student loan today
okay you'd be debt-free but your house
kind of weird you can still got thirty
two thousand dollars in your emergency
fund which in your house is enough for
your emergency fund if you want to save
for other purchases you save them in a
different account your rainy day fund is
not to be touched
unless it's raining it's only for
emergencies and you probably need about
thirty thousand bucks in there and you
got that leftover after you for debt
free then you're already putting money
into your retirement accounts aren't you
absolutely yes no we wouldn't mind put
more I have a different you know I don't
remember the number but I can put
another twenty percent in through a
different thing that is offered in Ohio
for teachers well I might do that or I
might do just Roth IRAs and good growth
stock mutual funds but I want you to put
fifteen percent of your household income
total into all your retirement programs
no more until you get your house paid
off and your kids college going I don't
what I don't want to put thirty BCAM
sure we we don't have kids we joke and
say they're gonna have vacations gotcha
that's good yeah okay so we can skip
baby step 5 so I want you to put no more
than fifteen percent of your income
fifteen percent point one five times 140
okay your end so you know we're talking
about twenty two thousand dollars okay
into retirement no more than that and
throw everything else at this little
dinky mortgage you got you got a small
mortgage
and you know what happen is in about
four years your house is going to be
paid for three years your house is gonna
be paid for and then you got no payments
in the world now you got nothing to do
but build wealth live and be generous
and lots of vacations oh absolutely
now I do have a very specific question
okay I I'm driving a car that is
affectionately we call it the moon shot
because it just now went to 250,000
miles which is about the rocks and the
distance to the moon and I Drive 1,500
miles a week for work I'm looking at
trying to upgrade to get better gas
mileage and would it be better to pay
off the car or I'm sorry buy a car
outright versus maybe paying off the
mortgage or vs. where I would never pay
once we're out of that we're never gonna
borrow again okay so you're gonna save
up and pay cash for this car okay even
even if even if I could get like a 0%
for 60 years no they're borrowing money
again okay it's a real clean way of
living it's very simple it's no stress
there's no risk no matter what happens
in the economy you've got all of your
income to build wealth and live and give
you can enjoy it you can build wealth
you can live in gift there's only three
things you can do with money spend it
give it and save it and you ought to be
doing all three but you can do more of
all of that when you don't know a dime
quit playing
all of these corporations games where
they make money on you the only 0%
interests are on new cars new cars lose
60% of their value to 70% of their value
in the first four years you shouldn't
buy a brand-new car until your debt free
you do need to move up in car I agree
with you but you pay cash for a one or a
two year old car whatever you're driving
you're destroying its value with that
miles anyway oh absolutely
you're you're running miles like crazy
so you don't wanna destroy a good car's
value you want to score it destroy a
medium reliable cars value hey hold on
I'm gonna have kelly send you a copy of
the book the Total Money Makeover that
describes all this to celebrate you
being a new listener we're honored to
have you sir